another protest for change marred by
violence for a second night police came
under attack from angry crowds in
central London bottles and fireworks
were thrown and bins settlement and they
all actually trampled over me they were
not bothered
pockets of disorder erupted early on and
police had to run for cover actions
condemned by the prime minister who said
people have a right to protest
peacefully and while observing social
distancing but they have no right to
attack the police these demonstrations
have been subverted by thuggery and
they're a betrayal of the cause they
purport to serve those responsible will
be held to account it was disheartening
to for the thousands of peaceful
demonstrators who marched outside the US
Embassy earlier in the day determined
that this show of solidarity is the
defining image this is not right this is
just a protest or speaking because we
haven't been able to speak for years
you've been oppressed pushed down and
pushed it aside you know I mean I think
it's important for not only myself for
the youngest generation to be a part of
it
I have an understanding understand it
there's a bigger picture out there of
wiping for happening to them
demonstrators in Bristol also made their
mark ripping down and drown me a
controversial statue of former slave
trader Edward Auster an act slammed by
the Home Secretary well I think that is
utterly disgraceful and that speaks to
the acts of disorder public disorder the
Rattray have now become a distraction
from the cause in which people are
actually actively protesting about the
statue of Winston Churchill also
couldn't escape vandals
more than four thousand miles from the
scene of George Floyd's death the cries
of injustice could be no clearer on the
streets of Britain but they may need to
be louder to block out those who are
tarnishing the movement - nahariya at
Sky News